used to do Street interviews and I would
ask guys would you rather have a woman
that has 50 bodies or fifty thousand
dollars in debt that you'd have to pay
off and most of the guys
said they'd pick the debt even even guys
that didn't make that much money they're
like you know what I'll pay off her debt
I am not I'm not doing the bodies so uh
so what does that inherently show that
we have value
from birth we are born with value where
men have to create their value men have
to become the things that women want
where women are just born the things
that men want and it's our job not to
destroy it and the problem is is older
women fat chicks will lie to
younger women about what men want and it
makes it very confusing for the next
generation of women when you see women
like Kim Kardashian and cardi B rewarded
for their decision now it's actually a
very logical path that women women take
you know